Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Ms Buffard's students
Bonjour, c'est Simon à l'appareil.
Alors, en fait, parfois pendant l'amour,
je pense à mon ex.
Je me demande si c'est normal, par
rapport à ma copine actuelle et tout ça.
Bonjour Point G.
Je m'appelle Maëva, j'ai dix-huit ans.
J'entends souvent que les femmes jouissent
systématiquement après les hommes,
comme si on était programmée
pour ça, en fait.
Comme si, les femmes,
ça prend plus de temps,
et les hommes, c'est censé
aller plus rapidement.
Voilà, le problème, c'est qu'avec
mon copain, c'est l'inverse.
C'est lui qui jouit toujours après moi,
du coup, je me demande
si je dois m'inquiéter.
Est-ce qu'on est anormaux ou pas ?
Voilà. Merci, PointG. Bisous.
Oui allo, bonjour.
C'est Pierre pour Point G.
Après l'amour, je ne suis pas très câlin,
mon copain voudrait
me prendre dans ses bras
mais moi j'ai besoin de
me retrouver un peu d'abord.
Il me dit que ce n'est pas normal
et ça m'inquiète un peu.
Voilà, j'aimerais avoir votre avis.
Merci beaucoup. [Bip sonore]
(Applaudissements)
Est-ce que je suis normal(e) ?
Ah, la voilà !
La grande question que j'entends
tous les soirs à l'antenne ou presque,
avec chaque auditeur ou presque,
que ce soit dit de façon explicite ou pas.
C'est aussi la grande question
qu'entendent tous les sexologues,
consultation après consultation.
Alors je sais, ça peut faire sourire.
Mais vous tous, tout au fond de vous,
je suis sûre
qu'au moins une fois dans votre vie,
vous vous êtes dit : « mais,
« Mais, pourquoi cette envie-là
tout à coup ? Pourquoi ce désir-là ?
Pourquoi j'ai fait ce rêve-là ?
Pourquoi ce fantasme-là ?
Pourquoi avec lui ? Avec elle ?
Pourquoi comme ça ?
Pourquoi maintenant ? Est-ce que
tout ça est très normal finalement ? »
A force, moi la question
que je me suis posée c'est :
« Mais en fait, ça veut dire quoi être
normal quand on parle de sexualité ?
La norme en matière
de sexualité, c'est quoi ?
Est-ce que la sexualité
peut être normale ?
Est-ce que c'est souhaitable ? »
Dans ces cas-là, quand on commence
à se poser ce genre de questions,
le mieux, ça reste un petit
retour aux fondamentaux,
donc on va regarder les définitions
du dictionnaire qui nous dit quoi ?
Le dictionnaire nous dit d'abord,
normal : qui est conforme
à la nature d'un être, d'une chose,
à l'organisation de cette chose,
qui est habituel, logique, ordinaire
Deuxième possibilité,
normal : qui est conforme à une moyenne
considérée comme une norme,
qui n'a donc rien d'exceptionnel ;
et enfin,
normal : qui sert de règle,
de modèle, de référence.
Alors ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on prenne toutes ces définitions
une par une
et on va voir si ça marche.
On va voir si la sexualité
peut être conforme
à la nature d'un être ou d'une chose,
si elle peut être habituelle,
logique ou ordinaire.
Salut PointG c'est Charlotte, j'appelle
pour votre émission ce soir sur l'orgasme.
Alors pour moi l'expression
qui résumerait le mieux cet état
c'est : « Je ne réponds plus de rien. »
Un moment où la sensation s'impose à vous,
à tel point qu'elle éclipse tout le reste
un peu comme, bizarrement, pendant
un éternuement ou des chatouilles.
Peut-être qu'on est jamais aussi présent
à soi-même que dans ce moment-là
et ça peut même mener à des
situations un peu embarrassantes.
Je me souviens avoir réagi,
assez récemment, un peu violemment
après un orgasme interrompu
involontairement par mon partenaire.
A base de : « Je te déteste,
ne me fais plus jamais ça. »
J'ai dû platement m'excuser après,
j'avais un petit peu la honte
de m'être comportée comme une bête.
Voilà, c'est ça l'orgasme, aussi.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on aime, entre autre.
Merci et bonne émission.
[Sonnerie]
Oui, l'orgasme,
c'est cet abandon complet
C'est ce lâcher-prise total qui va
chercher tout au fond de nous
et qui fait que non, quand on aime,
quand on désire,
plus rien n'est conforme
à la nature des choses.
On est hors de soi,
on est plus que soi.
On l'a tous senti ce cœur qui bat, cette
boule au ventre ou les ailes dans le dos.
Ça dépend des moments.
La pupille qui se dilate.
En tout cas le corps qui échappe,
la pensée qui tourne en boucle.
C'est parfaitement anormal et en
même temps c'est parfaitement naturel.
Les poètes parlaient d'ivresse des sens.
La médecine, la science a fini
par leur donner raison : oui,
quand on aime
on est toujours un peu saoul.
Toujours un peu fou.
En fait, en réponse à un stimuli
sensuel ou sexuel,
le cerveau va libérer
un cocktail d'hormones
qui va agir comme
un produit dopant naturel.
On va d'abord secréter de la dopamine,
l'hormone de la motivation et
de la récompense qui fait qu'à priori,
on a envie d'y retourner.
On va sécréter aussi,
quand tout va bien, des endorphines,
l'hormone du plaisir.
Et puis de l'ocytocine
qui est l'hormone de l'attachement.
On est en quelques sortes en sur-régime.
C'est manifeste en imagerie cérébrale.
Toutes les zones de la motivation sont
hyper-excitées quand cet état dure,
ça s'appelle de l'amour,
qui est biologiquement aveugle
puisque dans le même temps,
toutes les zones du jugement critique
sont comme endormies.
Oui, l'amour est par essence
parfaitement anormal
et quand on atteint
les sommets du plaisir, c'est pire encore.
Salut PointG, c'est Félix.
J'appelle pour l'émission de ce soir.
Qu'est-ce qu'on ressent
quand on a un orgasme ?
Pour moi l'orgasme c'est un peu
tout sentir et tout ressentir.
C'est ne rien sentir et ne rien ressentir.
C'est des émotions contradictoires
qui se succèdent comme une mitrailleuse
Je suis heureux, je suis bien,
puis je suis triste, je suis mélancolique.
J'ai envie de rire, j'ai envie de pleurer.
J'ai envie de...
C'est comme on l'appelle,
on appelle l'orgasme la petite mort
et ce n'est pas pour rien.
Parce qu'on se sent vivant,
on se fusionne avec l'autre.
On ne parle plus d'elle et de moi,
on parle de nous.
Il n'y a plus qu'un grand tout.
Le monde peut s'arrêter maintenant
et plus rien ne compte.
Avoir un orgasme c'est un peu
comme mourir un peu.
Voilà, passez une bonne soirée
et à bientôt. Au revoir.
Je vois que ça parle
à certains d'entre vous
ce qui est en soi une bonne nouvelle
alors oui effectivement.
Au moment de la montée maximale
du plaisir,
ça va chercher tout au fond de nous,
vers quelque chose de beaucoup plus
spontané, voire d'animal.
Une animalité qu'on passe pourtant sa vie
à tenter de civiliser, de domestiquer.
A coup de « ça se fait »
ou « ça ne se fait pas ».
Là, tout à coup, il n'y a plus tout ça.
C'est un moi beaucoup moins noble,
beaucoup moins raisonnable,
beaucoup moins lisse,
qui exulte.
Alors oui, ça dérange,
ça bouscule, ça fait peur.
On va avoir envie de se rapprocher
de ce qu'on peut, à des stéréotypes,
à des prêt-à-penser,
à des idées toutes faites
et puis aux autres surtout,
à l'immense masse des autres qui
nous entourent et dont on pense toujours
et dont on pense toujours qu'ils savent
mieux faire que nous parce que
eux ils font du moins,
c'est ce qu'on croit.
Donc on se raccroche
à ce qu'on croit qu'ils font.
En un mot, à la moyenne
des comportements, à la norme.
Mais cette fois à la norme statistique.
Et alors là, excellente nouvelle !
Pas une semaine ne se passe,
pas une journée ne se passe
sans qu'une nouvelle enquête,
un nouveau sondage, une nouvelle étude
un nouveau chiffre sur la sexualité
sur un internet ou à la télévision
ne nous donne du grain à moudre.
Par exemple celle-ci : 13,5 cm.
C'est la taille moyenne du pénis
des français selon l'université d'Ulster,
qui nous place « Cocorico » dans une bonne
moyenne, dans un classement européen,
en tout cas pas honteuse.
Messieurs, ne vérifiez pas
tout de suite s'il vous plaît.
On le sait, il n'y a pas
que la taille qui compte.
Et surtout ça n'empêche personne de
faire l'amour 97 fois par an en moyenne.
selon une étude Durex, soit environ
deux fois par semaine.
Ce qui satisfait visiblement
la plupart d'entre nous.
Enfin surtout les gauchers ! Oui.
86% des gauchers,
je suis gauchère,
86% des gauchers se disent extrêmement
satisfaits de leur vie sexuelle
contre 15% seulement des droitiers.
Alors quel est le rapport ?
Pas la moindre idée,
parce qu'évidemment les auteurs
de cette étude ne l'expliquent pas.
Ce serait trop beau.
Revenons en à ces deux fois !
Deux fois c'est bien.
Ah bah vous êtes gauchère madame,
je suis ravie pour vous.
Donc vous êtes dans les 86% sans doute.
Alors deux fois par semaine c'est bien.
Mais peu mieux faire.
Regardez ! A trois fois par semaine
selon une étude,
cette fois-ci de l'université d'Edimbourg.
Ce qui n'est pas rien.
Les personnes qui font l'amour
trois fois par semaine
paraissent 7 à 12 ans de moins
que leur âge réel.
Ouah !
Mieux que le Botox !
Alors, ajoutez une fois, et là jackpot !
Les personnes qui font l'amour
quatre fois par semaine
sont 5 % plus riches.
Accessoirement, elles sont aussi moins
dépressives et plus intelligentes.
Comme quoi, ne me demandez pas pourquoi !
Ce n'est évidemment pas donné.
Comme quoi, ce qui compte c'est
de faire et beaucoup si possible.
Le culte de la performance
dans lequel on a tous plongé
depuis une vingtaine d'année,
n'a pas épargné la sexualité.
La norme statistique en matière
de sexualité devient donc
celle du toujours plus, toujours
plus loin, toujours plus fort
et la seule question aujourd'hui,
ce n'est plus « Comment ? »
c'est surtout « Combien ? »
Oui bonjour ! J'appelle pour
l'émission PointG comme Giulia
Je voulais savoir s'il existait
une normalité dans la sexualité.
Alors il me semble que non parce que
voilà on dit souvent :
« Chacun son rythme » ,
« Chacun trouve son équilibre ».
Certes, mais voilà...
C'est quoi un bon rythme ?
Deux fois, trois fois, dix fois,
vingt fois par semaine
C'est un peu moche de
comptabiliser mais voilà,
est-ce qu'il y a un chiffre
clé une normalité ?
Oui je vous entends rire.
Moi aussi j'ai très envie de rire.
Sauf que je suis sûre que là,
dans la salle aujourd'hui
il y en a au moins quelques-uns
qui sont en train de se dire,
Attend je l'ai fait combien de fois ?
Est-ce que je suis bien ?
Est-ce que je suis bien dans la moyenne ?
Je vais les donner ces chiffres,
les vrais chiffres,
pas les pseudo-études internet.
En fait il y a une seule enquête sur notre
sexualité qui soit valable aujourd'hui.
C'est celle qu'ont faite les chercheurs
de l'INSERM publiée en 2008
et qui s'appelle
Contexte de la sexualité en France
Donc selon l'enquête CSF nous ferions
l'amour 9 fois par mois en moyenne.
Ça va ? Tout le monde est dedans ?
Neuf fois par mois en moyenne.
Attention ! Attention !
Quand on vit à deux,
ces chiffres baissent.
[Rires]
baissent...
et toujours selon
les chercheurs de l'INSERM
ceux qui sont en couple
depuis deux ou trois ans,
ils sont un sur dix a avoir
déclaré à ces chercheurs
qu'ils n'avaient pas fait
l'amour depuis 3 mois.
Voilà.
Les pratiques maintenant.
Si l'on en croit nos magazines préférés,
que personne ne lit mais
que toute le monde lit en fait.
Si on en croit les reportages télé,
nous serions tous devenus
SM, échangistes, libertins, pourquoi pas
les trois à la fois, tant qu'à faire.
On aurait tous un sex-toy coincé, calé,
dans le tiroir de la cuisine au cas où.
Bref on y va !
Bon alors, pareil selon l'enquête CSF,
3,6% des hommes et 1,7 % des femmes
ont déclaré avoir fréquenté une fois
dans leur vie un club échangiste.
En terme de phénomène de société...
on a vu mieux.
Les sex-toy : un célèbre hebdomadaire
féminin que je ne citerai pas, titrait,
il n'y a pas très longtemps :
« C'est vraiment la folie
des sex-toy en ce moment »,
et s'appuyait sur une étude qui disait que
45% des français utilisent des sex-toy.
Il faut toujours regarder à la fin
de ces études-là
comment elles ont été faites et par qui.
C'est toujours utile, parce que :
que cette étude ait été menée
par un fabricant de sextoy,
qu'il n'est donc interrogé
que ses clients,
et que les résultats éventuellement
l'arrangent, on s'en fout.
Qu'il reste tout de même 55% de français
qui n'utilisent pas de sextoy
on s'en moque aussi.
Non. Du moment qu'on peut titrer
« C'est vraiment la folie
des sextoy en ce moment ! »
Que nous dit l'enquête CSF sur le sujet ?
Elle nous dit que 78% des français
n'ont jamais utilisé de sextoy.
Je dis bien jamais.
Plus généralement,
les conclusions des chercheurs
de l'INSERM sont sans appel.
Pardon, mais le grand gang bang
n'a pas encore eu lieu.
Depuis la révolution
sexuelle des années 70,
pas ou peu de changement.
Surtout, on continue
de concevoir la sexualité
comme essentiellement hétérosexuelle,
pénétrative, conjugale.
Comme révolution, on a vu mieux.
Sauf que ça claque moins
et que ce qui compte quand même,
c'est de claquer.
Faire beaucoup, beaucoup de bruit parce
que face au silence de l'alcôve,
aux mystères de l'intime,
face à cet inconnu-là :
on a la trouille.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe pendant
qu'on fait l'amour, personne ne le sait.
Le désir est indicible.
Le plaisir est insaisissable.
Le ressenti est forcément subjectif.
Oui ça aussi ça nous échappe.
Oui, ça aussi, ça nous fait peur.
Alors que le chiffre, ça cadre,
ça rassure, ça norme.
Donc on mesure, on compare, on évalue.
Et là tout à coup, c'est magique.
Un glissement de sens s'opère
et cette norme qui était jusque-là
neutre et objective puisque chiffrée
se double de jugement moral
et ça n'est plus ce que
la moyenne des gens fait.
C'est plutôt ce que
tout le monde doit faire.
C'est-à-dire que la sexualité tout à coup
devient quelque chose d'obligé.
Elle est ce que la société autorise
et ce qu'elle interdit.
Si on a l'impression que tout le monde
fait tout, tout le temps, à tout va,
alors à la moindre pudeur,
à la moindre petite baisse de régime,
on se sent tout, tout petit,
plus vraiment dans la course.
Un peu anormal en fait.
Ce qu'on a oublié, c'est que ces études
ne disent rien de nous.
Oui, elles servent à une chose
et c'est fondamental.
Elles servent à prendre la température
d'une société à un instant t.
En revanche, de chacun d'entre vous,
elles ne disent rien.
De moi, elles ne disent rien.
Très franchement, je préfère faire l'amour
une seule fois par mois,
si cette fois-là est une apothéose
plutôt que 10 tannées par semaine.
Et je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi.
[Applaudissements]
Merci.
Ce qui me convient à moi,
ne vous conviendra pas à vous.
Ma sexualité,
elle est à moi et à moi seule.
Elle est à vous et à vous seule.
Pour une fois, les sciences dites 'dures'
sont d'accord avec les sciences humaines.
Les psychanalystes, les sexologues,
les neurolobiologistes
et j'en passe, sont tous d'accord
sur un point : nous sommes tous
comme programmés pour avoir
des désirs plus ou moins variés,
des fantasmes plus ou moins intenses,
des orgasmes plus ou moins puissants.
Et ça, c'est dû à une combinaison
de facteurs qui tient à la fois
de l'environnement, de la culture,
de la biologie, de nos parcours affectifs.
Ce sont ces ingrédients-là
qui font notre sexualité.
Et chacun va les cuisiner à sa manière.
De façon plus ou moins consciente,
pour aboutir
à un résultat
qui sera propre à chacun.
En fait les seules variations
qu'il faut prendre en compte,
c'est les variations par rapport à votre
désir habituel, votre plaisir habituel.
Ce qui compte c'est d'être
juste par rapport à vous.
Non, la sexualité elle ne peut
pas être normale,
parce qu'elle ne peut pas être normée.
Parce qu'elle est
par essence et par nature,
elle est unique, individuelle, singulière.
Oui ça aussi, ça fait un peu peur parce
qu'il n'y a pas de repère, de boussole.
On va dire qu'en gros,
à l'intérieur du cadre de la loi
et évidemment dans le consentement
des deux partenaires,
chacun fait exactement
comme il peut et comme il veut.
La question à se poser n'est pas :
« Est-ce que je suis normal ? »
C'est : « Mais j'ai envie de quoi ? »
Moi, j'ai envie de quoi ?
C'est une question qui est compliquée.
On peut mettre toute sa vie
avant de trouver la réponse et pire,
la réponse peut changer le lendemain
parce que le problème avec la sexualité,
c'est que c'est une matière vivante,
donc mouvante.
Ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui
ne le sera pas demain.
Néanmoins, cette question-là,
qui est complexe, qui peut faire peur,
qui peut être douloureuse aussi,
en même temps elle est libératrice.
Elle ouvre tout le champ des possibles.
Elle est surtout beaucoup plus juste.
Évidemment, je vais vous
la poser cette question-là.
Vous, tous là !
Vous avez envie de quoi ?
Merci.
[Applaudissements]